Our gross total consolidated revenue grew a healthy 20% year-over-year to $16.5 billion dollars...
...and was up 4% quarter over quarter.
Google Sites' revenue was also up 20% year-over-year to $11.3 billion...
...and was up 3% quarter over quarter, driven by the strength in our mobile search.
US revenue was up to 15% year-over-year to 7 billion dollars.
The UK was up 17% year-over-year to $1.6 billion.
Our non-US revenue excluding the UK was up 26% year-over-year to 7.9 billion dollars.
This accounted for 48% of total revenue,...
...which includes a $10 million benefit from our hedging program.
Case in point, we're really excited about this week's Android Lollipop launch.
This is our largest release on Android ever with over 5,000 APIs for developers.
It adds new features, including better notifications, battery life and security...
...and introduces a refreshed, consistent visual style.
On the hardware front, just yesterday, we unveiled three fantastic new Nexus devices:...
...Nexus 6 phone, Nexus 9 tablet and Nexus Player,...
...an Android-powered streaming media player.
We're also selling Chromebook in six new countries.
They're now available in 31 countries around the world.
And we sold more than one million Chromebooks for education this quarter.
And we were so proud to launch Android One,...
...an effort to make high-quality, low-cost smartphones...
...available to as many people as possible.
We started in India and we'll be expanding to other countries...
...including Indonesia and the Philippines in the coming months.